de la terre et des débris voilà la scène
qui attendait ce matin la famille
vautour la roulotte les cabanons
typiques et véhicules récréatifs ont
tous été enlevés seuls ces fleurs n'ont
pas été touchées c'est là que les
cendres de Jackie vautour et donne ses
fils sont enterrés il y a personne qui
sait
ils savent pas quoi ce qu'ils nous ont
fait Maureen vautour est en colère elle
revit le cauchemar de son enfance
lorsqu'on 1976 par Canada a détruit la
maison familiale son père Jacky refusait
de quitter le parc alors que Navy
d'expropriation forçait plus de 200
familles à déménager quand je leur
c'était la mort
Jacky va tourne jamais baissé les bras
il est même revenu vivre dans le parc il
a installé une petite roulotte il y a
vécu avec sa famille sans au courant et
sans électricité
il a continué à lutter pour faire
reconnaître son droit de vivre dans le
parc même vieillard il y vivait toujours
avec sa femme il y est resté jusqu'à sa
mort en 2021
parce que
vraiment la cause mérite d'argan et
Jacky vautour a essayé plusieurs fois de
convaincre les tribunaux sans jamais
avoir gain de cause
hier parc Canada a décidé que s'en était
assez des policiers ont fermé la route
qui mènent à la maison des vautours ou
un fils il vivait toujours pendant que
par Canada loin des regards faisait
enlever les biens des vautours la
nouvelle a fait le tour de la région ça
fait vraiment mal de voir qu'une
deuxième fois que ça se produit de la
même manière je vais dire que ce qu'on a
fait des démolios on est tous sauver le
monde
comme cet homme pense que la lutte a
assez duré d'autant plus que Jackie
vautour avait reçu une compensation
financière du gouvernement du
Nouveau-Brunswick parc le Canada de son
côté rappelle que l'occupation était
illégale et qu'il avait survenu
ultimatum à la famille l'année dernière
les biens des vautours ont été mis dans
des boîtes et entreposées à l'extérieur
du parc il pense qu'il nous avons parce
qu'ils ont fait
la police
parce que
la famille n'a pas l'intention
d'abandonner la lutte ici Michel Bridoux
Radio-Canada